until Disney decides to release another
trilogy in the mainline series Star Wars
Episode nine the rise of Skywalker is
the final bow on the 42 year package
that is the Skywalker saga and while it
answers a lot of long-standing questions
it also raises just as many questions as
it answers here are some of the big ones
and of course spoilers are ahead one
burning question the movie answers with
in its opening minutes is whether
Emperor Palpatine is alive and he is
he's not a force ghost and not
identified as a clone he's the full-on
flesh-and-blood sheev Palpatine being
kept alive by a very tall mechanical
life-support system nothing he
communicates to kylo Ren Rey or general
pride mentions any words about how he
survived being thrown down a giant pit
at the end of Return of the Jedi nobody
bothers to ask him either everybody who
now knows the Emperor is back including
Luke Skywalker's force ghost who you'd
think would be really curious to learn
how Palpatine made it out of that pickle
just kind of rolls with it even the
resistance spends only a few minutes
being incredulous before simply
accepting that Palpatine is alive and
kicking the rise of Skywalker's biggest
revelation is the truth of Rey's
parentage after meeting Palpatine on the
Sith planet ex ago kylo Ren learns that
what he knew about Rey's parents was
only partially true yes they sold her
yes they were basically nobody but it
was all intentional they made themselves
anonymous and left Rey behind because
her father was Emperor Palpatine Sun
making Rey the Emperor's granddaughter
but hold up a minute
Emperor Palpatine had a son when let's
try to work it out if the Emperor's
family ages like other humans Rey is
probably in her early 20s by the time
the rise of Skywalker takes place which
would mean her father would probably
have been born 40 to 50 years earlier
given how he looks in flashbacks
so Palpatine jr. would probably have
been born sometime between the prequel
trilogy and the original trilogy so
where was he during the original trilogy
who was his mother was the younger
Palpatine a clone like his illegitimate
son and the old extended universe it
isn't addressed
so your guesses are as good as anyone
elses long I have waited that ominous
statement from Emperor Palpatine is
essentially his greeting to his
granddaughter Rey but why spend decades
just sitting around on x ago presumably
because he was waiting for his fleet of
planet exploding star destroyers to be
finished but we're also told that he
tried to have Rey brought to him when
she was just a child
so what really was his plan why did he
need to create Snoke to be his puppet
could he not have just shown back up and
started the first order himself perhaps
he was too physically weak but he was
hardy enough to create all those Snoke
clones why did he have to use kylo Ren
as his intermediary rather than going
directly to Rey she may have been well
hidden for a while but eventually she
made herself very well known why did
Palpatine's plan have to be so
complicated sometimes I just didn't
understand human behavior Rey in the
gang find a dagger on a cheese ship that
has the directions to one of the Sith
wayfinders written on but there's a
catch it's written in the ancient Sith
language and that's not something they
teach in scavengers school on jakku
c-3po is able to read it but can't relay
a translation to his pals because his
programming forbids it when he starts to
explain that there is some legalities
behind that prohibition involving the
Galactic Senate HOH cuts him off before
he can get into the details
our heroes get around that roadblock by
having droid Smith Babu Frick do a
potentially dangerous and definitely
unethical procedure to extract the
information but let's back up a bit
how to c-3po no Sith by the time Anakin
Skywalker built the droid from spare
parts Sith speak would seemingly have
only been a language used by the highly
secretive Sith order which had been in
hiding for hundreds of years
maybe c-3po s parts were really really
old and from a time when Sith was a lot
more common or maybe his language
software is just really really good
chief Palpatine knows how to play a
crowd he treat thunderous applause while
Liberty died
remember he similarly gets his audience
of black robed figures white-hot with
excitement as he dares Rey to strike him
down on X ago he has them eating right
out of his horribly disfigured hands
just one question though who are those
people in the stands they're almost
assuredly Sith of one type or another
since X ago is the secret sit homeworld
but are they living creatures are they
more beings he created like he did with
Snoke aren't they the spirits of all the
Sith who lived in the past
Palpatine says he contains all of the
Sith within him is that them it they
built his fleet of planet exploding star
destroyers or did it go ray claims the
names Skywalker at the end of the movie
making her at least one of the
Skywalker's who rise in the movie she
uses the combined force energy of every
Jedi who ever put on a robe to defeat
her grandfather deflecting his own Force
Lightning back at him and she helps
redeemed in Solo he does a lot of good
things but Palpatine makes the deal very
clear if she kills him
she becomes the Empress so even though
she doesn't absorb his life force like
he planned isn't she the Empress by
birthright by order of succession
there's no Republic to go back to any
longer they got wiped out sure Rey may
just dissolve everything and start a new
new Republic but there's a slew of first
order and final order loyalists out
there desperate for a leader to tell
them what to do it may be raised
responsibility to say if nothing else
hit the bricks
okay Evie is the head that wears the
hood right check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Star Wars are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]